hey 42 here the average thickness of ice
in Antarctica is about one mile welcome
to RIF the father a cat Falls the better
cats are less likely to be injured if
they fall from greater heights when cats
fall from five stories or higher they
reach terminal velocity and relax their
bodies which slows them down and
protects them from the impact New
Zealand will deny people's residency
visas if their BMI is too high and there
have been cases where people have been
rejected because of their weight Abraham
Lincoln kept his most important
documents inside his hat
world's most expensive phone number is
666 six six six six it was sold in 2006
for 1.5 million pounds in ancient Rome
men found guilty of rape had their
testicles crushed between two stones
when building the Golden Gate Bridge the
lead structural engineer insisted on the
installation of a safety net even though
it's $130,000 cast was deemed exorbitant
over the four years of its construction
the net saved 19 men from certain death
who named themselves the halfway to hell
a physicist made his cat the co-author
of his scientific paper to avoid using I
instead of we threw out the paper an
elephant's trunk has no bones but 40,000
muscles cat
kidneys are so efficient they can
rehydrate by drinking seawater the law
enforcement in a town in northern Spain
has ordered that all prostitutes in the
town must wear reflective vests whilst
working to avoid traffic accidents at
night before the Holocaust Hitler gave
the US the UK and many other nations the
chance to take in Jewish refugees but
they all refused every panda in the
world is on loan from China the logo of
the new
zealand air force is the kiwi a
flightless bird after working out it
takes five hours for your body
temperature to return to normal
india's go air airline only hires female
flight attendants because they are
lighter so they save up to five hundred
thousand US dollars per year in fuel
thanks for the view subscribe for more
thoughty2